because you're promoting this film and
people are talking to you about
relations of it so there's Lucknow it is
like the Gospel according to come in yes
all these you've these edicts have come
on hi Cameron Diaz as Sanford's everyone
gets cheated on at some point yeah are
you standing by this yeah cheated on
don't know okay cheated on I'm talking
about like from like the first boys or
girls yeah exactly like there is
somebody else somebody that you tell me
he was kissing that was kissing somebody
else you didn't know me very well be
yeah skip forward to my mid twin so if
somebody's watching this they haven't
been cheated on they're going to be well
look it I'm not gonna I'm not saying
that cheaters are like are cheater in
this movie I'm not saying that it's like
a pathological situation I'm just saying
that there's a moment in everybody's
time where they feel that they find that
somebody has betrayed them at some level
betrayal is that is that more
comfortable for people more comfortable
I see people when they say that they're
like all of a sudden they get really
nervous they're always like they go
through all of their boyfriends and
their girlfriends are like did I oh my
god all of a sudden they start
questioning it becomes like this
completely existential like conundrum
they're like did I did I did I and like
just relax it's okay if you did
everybody gets cheated on
really has nobody appears there from me
to you guys but here's the other thing
because Cameron you're single at the
moment I am and Kylie you're single at
the moment hmm now meeting people in
dating is hard enough but Cameron Diaz
and Kylie I'm single
I'm going to include you sure lucky for
you Russell I'm married okay
oh you may be able to step it up in
there no how look - koukin guys ask you
out
yeah but how is it possible you just ask
but no don't encourage people I would
say yeah no it happens I know it's so
weird cuz we're just like it almost like
a disease or something yes
[Applause]
not that many people are no equity for
you though one of your ladies and
waiting at least there's a process they
know it's called betting betting right
so do they go through people
no so well I say that but actually in
when you know you work a lot I work a
lot
you have your team and you have your
people who can give you whispers down
the corridor and you know it's stuff
like that so not not vetting so much but
so does it come back does the message
come back are we if you were to ask
mister no god no
I'm so not pushed like that no no like
hey it no it says it's as awkward as it
is everyone would be like hey um so you
want to go for it or well you know we're
going out afterwards you want to go for
a drink I mean it happens like that
let's put this out to the group Cameron
has also been in the papers recently
he's very strongly that all woman should
maintain some pubic hair Catherine feels
very strongly about this
that would be retaining an aspect of
husbandry about attraction even would be
to maintain take it out every now and
then comb it in terms of my comfort zone
I'm far away from it of safety that is
an inappropriate metaphor
[Applause]
we're talking okay can I just clear
something up right yes please - if you
live okay did you ever ask you a
question like why are you there why are
you there why
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
sixteen some dodgy theater in Auckland
New Zealand I'm only bringing this up
because the title of the film was
Virginia the talking vagina that's all I
have to contribute meanwhile the
situation is is that I believe that we
should be informed as to how our body
works we should have the information and
I brought up the conversation about how
women are sort of young women as a sort
of trend are lasering off all of it at
one reservoir for thank you very much
for evermore and I just want to say to
the women who think at this moment for
whatever reason whether it's because
they've seen it may think that it's sexy
or that their man thinks that it's sexy
or whatever they they're tired of
dealing with it
[Applause]
[Music]
everybody's been talking about so I
believe that if you're doing something
forever ever change your mind and the
man who thinks it's sexy now you might
change your mind about him too he might
turn out to be a total like you should
consider what forever means and because
once it's gone you can't get it back
[Applause]
care take it all off for years I don't
care what up but when you want to take
that make that choice to bring it back
thank you do the back cracking sack
I do know I do a little manscaping for
friends yeah I mark it out you know with
one of those long things I think well if
they haven't bothered going here Kylie
you're right charlie
not much ribbon this big fat kid right
now the ankles smack went down like a
sack of [ __ ] thanks for coming
did you see that terrible Kylie wax when
I showed in the monologue this is so bad